so republican senator rick scott uh
wants america to get back to work now
it's a strange talking point to use when
unemployment is as low as it's
essentially been for 50 years so we're
going to look at this video and the
important thing to think about here is
once you commit to certain talking
points as the republican party has
you can't change them based on what's
going on and we've seen this with debt
and deficit we've got to balance the
budget well republican presidents never
do so they just stop talking about it
when a republican is in office and
blowing up the deficit but they don't
abandon the talking point they just
don't mention it anymore now that
there's a democrat in the white house
they have to go to america it's got to
get back to work we need people working
and people are working and we're going
to look at those numbers but check out
rick scott when all you've got is a
hammer everything looks like a nail or
whatever you want to say but the talking
point is republicans get people to work
democrats are lazy and so when there's a
democratic president people don't work
doesn't matter if it doesn't line up
with the facts but here's what i believe
we've got to get americans back to work
if you're able bodied you don't have
young children
you know incapacity dependent get to
work right just go stop being lazy if
you're not handicapped if you don't have
a disability if you don't have a
physical issue i get i mean maybe they
would consider mental issues too i don't
know that's a touch and go with
republicans they claim to care about
mental health but then they don't seem
to you got to get to work because
nobody's working these days and it's
part of the culture and the economic
policy of biden and then you look at the
unemployment rate and you see that the
unemployment rate right now
is essentially as low as it's been
since the early 1970s you have to go i
mean okay you've had this brief period
in 2019
and then you've got to go all the way
back
to the early 1970s to find a period
during which unemployment was this low
now i know that there are people going
to hear me say that
and they'll say but david the
unemployment rate tells us nothing the
truth is in the labor participation rate
remember we've talked about this claim
from the right for the last decade and
i've explained the labor participation
rate many times before and i will do it
again now the labor participation rate
is a more complicated issue and i'll
tell you why in a moment but when you
look at the labor participation rate
you'll find that it's right around 62
percent
roughly where it was in 2015 as well now
why isn't the labor participation rate a
really great indicator for the health of
the economy well there's a couple of
different things number one
the size of our population keeps growing
so
at almost any time period you can
accurately say
there are more people than ever working
and there are more people than ever not
working so what does that really tell us
but there's also a few important things
to consider number one
we are in the midst of a significant
retiring phase for baby boomers that
takes people out of the labor force is
is it an indicator the economy is bad no
in fact you could argue it's an
indicator the economy is good when
people can afford to retire it signals
that you have an okay economy
the other thing about this is that when
you look at the labor force
participation rate
if you have
full-time parents
who aren't working by choice that lowers
the labor labor participation rate but
that's a good thing when the economy
gets worse some of those full-time
parents say hey i can't afford not to
work i have to go and get a job labor
participation rate goes up but not
because the economy is good it's
actually because the economy is bad and
also as another reminder um
if you're in college undergrads in
college
if you're just in school full-time you
count against the labor participation
rate but again when there's a better
economy
18 to 22 year olds can afford to go to
school full-time instead of having to
get a job to help
help their family help their parents or
whatever the case may be so labor
participation rate not a good indicator
back to the main point
we have right now
um
significant levels of employment
we have a labor participation rate that
is normal it's not particularly high or
particularly low you have many um
companies looking to hire and yes we
have high inflation which i believe has
peaked and is going to start coming down
gas prices have already been coming down
for the last six weeks etc it is very
hard to argue that this is a disastrous
economy now you can also talk about
wages
inflation-adjusted wages
are actually doing okay have there been
if you look at a 40-year period stagnant
wages has productivity growth
dramatically outpaced uh
inflation-adjusted wages yes and that's
a bigger issue that relates to
technology
and corporate power and so many
different things but by the standards we
use to look at wages
we've seen some pretty okay wage
increases so while they have not kept up
with productivity there is no doubt that
that indicator also isn't a sign of this
terrible economy so rick scott and other
republicans
there has never been a time
even under barack obama during this
massive recovery from the uh
2008-2009 recession even then when we
started to see unemployment drop the
stock market explode consumer confidence
go up inflation very very controlled
even then they weren't willing to accept
it and as i said before many of these
things only have a little bit to do with
the president anyway but once you're
married to these talking points you have
to stick with them and that's exactly
what we are seeing
there is a new story involving secret
service text messages related to the
trump riots that has now gone viral and
exploded i'm going to tell you what's
going on and remember just because text
messages have been erased doesn't mean
they aren't retrievable and indeed the
latest news is that the text messages
despite being deleted are going to be
retrieved so let's jump into the story
cnbc report
january 6th panel subpoena secret
service for erased texts the house
committee investigating the u.s capitol
attack subpoenaed the secret service for
text messages agents reportedly deleted
right around january 6 2021 the date of
the trump riots committee chairman benny
thompson said in a statement the
committee understands the messages had
been erased
thompson outlined an aggressive timeline
for the production of the documents by
tuesday that's tomorrow and i'll tell
you in a moment whether they are going
to have the text messages by that date
the guardian reports january 6th
committee to receive deleted secret
service texts according to democrat
agency's account of how texts sent on
capital attack and day before were lost
has shifted several times when you get
different explanations for the same
occurrence it's not proof that someone
is lying but it's at least a suggestion
that you should be looking into what the
hell is going on
uh deleted secret service text sent on
january 6 the day of the insurrection at
the u.s capitol
will be released by tuesday to the house
committee
you can imagine how shocked we were to
get the letter from the department of
homeland security inspector general
saying he'd been trying to get this
information and they had in fact been
deleted after he asked for them said zoe
lofgren to uh abc's this week we need
all the texts to get the full picture
this is the interesting part the secret
services account about how text messages
from the day before
and the day of the capital attack were a
race has shifted several times
at one point the explanation from the
secret service for the lost texts was
because of software upgrades according
to the inspector general at another
point the explanation was because of
device replacements
the inspector general also said that
though the secret service opted to have
his office do a review of the agency's
response to the capital attack in lieu
of conducting action reports it then
stonewalled the review by slow walking
production materials there were claims
during the trump administration that
even the secret service which is widely
i don't know if widely considered but
widely expected to be an apolitical
organization
involved only in protecting
uh individuals in positions of power
including the president their family and
others even though that's the idea
the allegations during the trump
presidency were that even secret service
had turned political and that there were
essentially trump hacks within secret
service maybe not at the highest levels
but at medium and agent levels
if indeed
that was the case it would make sense
that they would all of a sudden be
wanting to be very cloudy about what
took place on january 5th and january 6.
particularly now in light of cassidy
hutchinson's claims before the committee
that trump tried to get secret service
to take him to the capitol for the riot
that trump tried to commandeer a vehicle
that trump lunged at a secret service
agent and on and on and on so the
circumstantial case would give us a
number of reasons to suspect why
the secret service might just just not
have accidentally deleted the exact test
texts that were requested as of this
morning deleted secret service texts to
be sent to january 6 committee by
tuesday tomorrow so it does appear
as though the secret service texts
will be turned over and on thursday
night is what is at least for now
considered to be
the last uh january 6th hearing we will
see what role these text messages play
then you really can't make this stuff up
now
remember as we are learning here deleted
and retrievable are two different things
and if you zoom out for a moment and
think about january 5 january 6th
trump's daily visitor and call log
has that very suspicious seven hour gap
talked about that months ago
mike pence didn't want to get into the
car with secret service when the rioters
were getting into the house the uh
capitol
and they were chanting hang mike pence
and a gallows had been built
pence was hesitant to get into the car
with secret service why exactly we don't
know
and now we have the allegation and it
seems to be proven that secret service
texts were deleted look at the pattern
extraordinarily odd extraordinarily
bizarre and in the next 72 to 96 hours
we may have more insights into exactly
what is in those text messages let me
know what you expect find me on twitter
at dpakman we'll take a quick break and
be right back
don't forget that the best way to
support the david pakman show is by
becoming a member which gives you access
to the daily bonus show the regular show
with no commercials you also get access
to our entire archive of every episode
dating back
a really long time and plenty of other
awesome membership perks go to
joinpackman.com
and use the coupon code better21 for a
huge discount join pacman.com
we are going to be doing the next david
pakman show live town hall next tuesday
july 26th it is going to be um 6 p.m
eastern time 3 p.m pacific it will be on
the pacman live youtube channel like
we've been doing recently would love for
you to call in everyone is welcome to do
so make sure you're subscribed at
youtube.com
pacman live more info forthcoming but
looking forward to it we'll take all
questions for about an hour and a half
and uh that will be that also remember
you can sign up at joinpakman.com the
david pakman show viewer and listener
supported you can use the coupon code
big voting 22 to get a discount at
joinpakman.com so this is the expected
result
of what is happening nationally
with abortion rights and with roe v wade
we
talked about
last week how this was a concern this
was something that was expected to
happen
and now it is happening texas hospitals
are refusing to see people
with serious pregnancy issues for fear
of violating post row abortion ban
according to a medical group we talked
about it 10 days ago and much like with
other things people wrote in saying
david that's hypothetical david that's
theoretical well it's now reportedly
happening check this out the texas
medical association says some hospitals
are refusing emergency care for
pregnancy complications they fear
violating the near total abortion ban in
texas the group said a woman was refused
treatment for her ectopic pregnancy
until it eventually ruptured this is per
the dallas morning news in a letter to
the texas medical board seen by the
newspaper the association said it
received numerous complaints that
hospitals were blocking doctors from
giving pregnant people medically
necessary care
which includes ending a pregnancy
remember that when i first reported on
this
some of the responses were david that's
not going to happen because there are
exceptions in these bills
and as i pointed out the medical
exceptions in the texas abortion bill
really are
up to the discretion of the doctor
and
can easily lead to gray area scenarios
where the doctors are afraid of being
second guessed not only by lawyers by
but by politicians sued for the actions
that they decide to take and even if it
would apparently be legal and even if
you fought it and defend yourself and
get a lawyer and ultimately prevail
what doctor wants to deal with that even
if you believe you will ultimately come
up on the right side of the law
do you really want to be dealing with
that for years because that's how long a
lot of these things uh will take so the
exceptions explanation is bogus the
article goes on to say
um
according to the paper the letter
described one case of a woman who had an
ectopic pregnancy which allows uh the
pregnancy that grows in the fallopian
tubes will never be viable but will be
life-threatening she was said to have
been refused treatment until her
pregnancy ruptured when you delay
or prevent care in that scenario it
creates a substantial risk for the
patient's future reproductive ability
and poses a serious risk to the
patient's immediate physical well-being
understand that with this condition
uh doctors know this is not going to
ultimately lead to
uh
a live human i i don't even know the
words to use it's just not
and
the correct thing in these situations
is to assist in terminating the
pregnancy
if you don't not only can you put the a
pregnant woman at health risk
you can also jeopardize her ability to
even have future
uh healthy babies and doctors are saying
even though that's the case
the risk to me legally
feels so great
that we may and in this case did refuse
treatment the forced birth people
keep emailing me saying oh you're
fear-mongering about that you're
fear-mongering about that and of course
it's now happening exactly as predicted
and by the way you know for all of the
claims that they are pro-life
when the mother dies
if it's before the fetus is viable
the fetus dies too not exactly pro-life
to say two deaths instead of what they
believe to be one and when you think
about what's happening in texas it
doesn't really sound like a developed
country i mean zoom out i tweeted about
this if i told you there's a place on
this planet it has a notably higher
infant mortality rate than much of the
developed world talking about texas
doctors are afraid of treating women
with pregnancy complications because
there's crazy anti-abortion laws
inspired by the religion of the people
passing them which makes the doctors
worried they'll get arrested for
providing care talking about texas and
also they're working in facilities in
hospitals
whose power might go out
because they are dependent on generators
in some cases because they've got this
isolated power grid without redundancy
now they have that by choice not by
necessity there are lots of parts of the
world where what i just described is not
by choice most people would not assume
that that's the state of texas when i
give you those three things higher than
than
most of the developed world infant
mortality um
doctors fearing
giving people the medical treatment they
need for fear of arrest and worries
about the power going out because of an
isolated power grid i don't know what
most people would think but most people
would not think that it's a state in the
united states that's what's going on
in texas and it's completely predictable
and it wasn't just us predicting it it's
now happening
uh there is a video clip i'm going to
play for you here
of maria bartiromo a fox
news host who has gone from pretty damn
good financial reporter 20 years ago to
conspiracy theorist trump brownnoser
suggesting on her sunday show yesterday
that joe biden is being fed drugs in
order to function and that barack obama
and jill biden may have known it and
helped to cover it up
and asking who is really running
this white house it's quite a theory
i must say
and during the clip i'm gonna play for
you if you're watching you'll actually
see them put up a four box graphic of
the people they suspect might really be
running the white house might really be
in charge we're supposed to believe that
this is a news channel
this is supposedly a news program on fox
not an opinion show all right let's take
a look at it congressman there were
signs that joe biden and actually let me
just even add before before we do this
maria bartiromo is interviewing ronnie
jackson ronnie jackson is trump's former
doctor who claimed trump is 6'3 and
weighs 239 pounds uh that's who's being
interviewed for context congressman
there were signs that joe biden was
declining during the 2020 campaign i
mean let's face it he stayed in the
basement the whole time during during
the campaign
so who knew what when are they hiding
this and feeding him drugs to to allow
him to function i know he goes home to
delaware a lot more than any other
president so shocking that he's in
delaware more than other presidents huh
i guess my question is what did obama
know what did jill biden know and who's
running the white house right now and
are they covering up for these mental uh
there could be a cover-up here issues
well that's the big question everybody's
asking who's really pulling the strings
who's running everybody's asking this
guys i mean listen ronnie jackson's
telling you the country right now we
don't really know the answer to that we
don't know if it's susan ross or ron
klainer if it's joe biden or who it is
but somebody else is doing this they're
doing exactly what you said they're
rolling him out at specific times and by
the way
they have this graphic immediately ready
so it's very hard to believe that they
had a graphic ready with the exact
people that ronnie jackson mentions
putting up this four box is it really
susan rice running the white house is it
ron clayne brian diese or jill biden
during the day he's got good days and
bad days good uh you know and whether or
not they have him on drugs i don't know
there are drugs out there that can
increase your alertness and your memory
and things of that nature you know and
cover stuff like this up temporarily so
i'm sure some of that's going on as well
but we don't know because his physician
hasn't stood up and took the questions
that i took when i was trump's physician
and answered those questions now it's
interesting how ronnie jackson says we
don't know but it does seem that that's
what's going on i mean he has no
knowledge of it it's not actually known
but he believes that it is going on he
says it must it is what's going on we're
supposed to believe this is a news
channel now aside from the level of
irresponsibility in this
i want to
mention one other aspect of this entire
joe biden thing now you all if you've
been watching this
my show you know i've said
the 2022 and 2020 joe biden are not 2012
joe biden joe biden humiliated paul ryan
in the 2012 debates ran circles around
him uh
had a rapidity and facility with the
facts and arguments that is is not where
joe biden is right now joe biden's
nearly 80 years old and that would be
common common if not typical of someone
his age but there's a couple different
things going on first the level of total
irresponsibility on what are supposedly
news programs now there has been
speculation about joe biden which i
engage in as well
uh on opinion programs and there has
been speculation about trump as well but
fox claims to be news and think back to
when trump got out of his uh plane and
and his car was right in front of him
and he just wandered off and had to be
brought back by secret service when he
was sitting across from rudy giuliani
and said where's rudy and looked around
when he said he wants to get to the
oranges of the investigation when he
referred to his himself as trump instead
of trump when he referred to barack
obama as obama when he talked about the
drock boxes and wait i could give you
the fox was silent
box was silent so there's also that
hypocrisy and then lastly
when they talk about biden was in his
basement
if biden was in his basement
and suffering from cognitive decline
doesn't it make it even more humiliating
that a guy suffering from cognitive
decline who didn't leave his basement
got eight million more votes than the
sitting president now their counter
would be well those numbers were fake so
now you've got two conspiracies you've
got the cover-up of the cognitive
decline and the theft of the election at
some point we have to say guys that's it
that's it
it's it's too far but they don't even
seem to get get how humiliating it is
for trump to have lost if those indeed
are the situations everyone is asking
this ronnie jackson says wait they are
that's news fox news which they claim to
be
uh folks it looks to me
that california governor gavin newsom
is running for president in 2024.
california governor gavin newsom was
interviewed by fox la
and gavin newsom comes out swinging and
points out exactly what i've been saying
about democrats for a decade now gavin
newsom says we shouldn't be playing
defense we should be playing offense
democrats must be ferocious democrats
must be ruthless
this is exactly what i have been saying
for over a decade on this program
i am not saying
that gavin newsom is uh my preferred
politician that i agree with him on
every issue that he's the epitome of a
progressive
but this guy
identifies the exact issue is using the
right language is pointing out exactly
what i've been pointing out
he's coming out swinging take a look at
this from his interview over the weekend
you have to also recognize that what
you're up against and right now we're up
against the ruthlessness of a republican
party and i say that
not naively i don't say that
i'm not that's not a cheap shot you see
what's happening to all the progress
we've made in the 21st century
all of the rights
that we in many ways have taken for
granted that have been afforded since
the 60s are being rolled back in real
time this is a totally different moment
and we have to wake up with a different
mindset
and not just old mindset in terms of
just a collaborative mindset a cup of
tea and everyone's going to work
together to get along big ways
to advance the collective cause and
that's where the party needs to come in
democrats need the democratic party not
the president not a speaker not a
elected office holder guys he's pointing
out the absurdity of thinking you're
gonna have a cup of tea with the modern
republican party and figure things out
and hash things out with them he is
exactly correct the party the
infrastructure i think has to organize
with more ferocity of focus
more determination to set the agenda set
the course and put the other party on
the defense they are dominating the
narrative the facts aren't on their side
but they're dominating there and in this
world right now you dominate the
narrative you win and that's what i'm
worried about and that's what i'm
expressing
so this is all part of his gubernatorial
campaign for re-election but he is doing
a lot of different things that suggest
greater ambitions he is running ads in
florida saying hey you want to come to
the place with real freedom leave
florida come to california he's doing
interviews in which he is addressing the
major issues facing structurally uh from
a pr perspective from a messaging
perspective facing the democratic party
i'm not endorsing gavin newsom he's not
even running he's not the most
progressive but this is a guy who could
be president now if he ran the smear
campaign would be brutal but it would
also be pretty toothless i mean okay
stuff about his dating history you know
he he was once married to kimberly
guilfoyle now who is now married to
donald trump jr that's weird that
doesn't that that's you know it makes it
makes me question someone's choices
that's for sure he had this dinner at
the expensive restaurant the french
laundry during covid when you weren't
supposed to be doing that that was wrong
that was and he's gonna get he's going
to get hit with that but
they are potentially going to expose
themselves if they have to run against
newsome because from what's known at
least right now
the criticisms and attacks on him would
be brutal but also quite toothless and
gavin newsom is 100 correct here they
have to be playing defense they're the
ones who are out of step with the views
of the american people why is it that
the left is constantly playing defense
they are the ones who are proposing
policy that would be disastrous for
millions of americans whether it's on
health care whether it's getting rid of
roe v whatever the case is
he's getting it and he is speaking about
it in a way that i'm not really hearing
anybody else talk about it right now
so
not endorsing anyone
it's very interesting that he has got
this messaging down pat because this is
the right messaging and by the way
this messaging is much more relevant on
the national stage and when you think
okay california california has large
geographic areas that are conservative
but from a population standpoint
california is not conservative and when
he talks about the strategy and tactics
that are required against this
republican party
it's fine to keep it in mind if you're
running for governor in california but
really it's relevant nationally so this
is super interesting we'll have this
interview on our instagram at david
pakman show check it out tell me what
you think i'm liking what i'm hearing
if you value what we do at the david
pakman show remember to support us on
patreon go to patreon.com david pakman
show where you can get access to behind
the scenes videos the daily bonus show
the commercial free daily show as well
as special discounts on merch including
hats hoodies
mugs and t-shirts
you can support the show for as little
as two dollars a month
check it out at patreon.com david pakman
show it increasingly is looking like all
but a foregone conclusion that failed
former president donald trump will run
again and will run again specifically
because he believes and is telling the
people around him that is the one way
that he can avoid criminal prosecution
for the things that he has done we're
going to get in a moment to a new legal
analysis of whether donald trump is
heading to an indictment we're going to
get to that but before we get to that a
blockbuster new report from rolling
stone trump tells team he needs to be
president again
to save himself
from criminal probes the former
president is planning on running for the
white house and away from the law
increasingly it is believed trump may
even announce before the november
midterms when donald trump formally
declares his 2024 candidacy he won't
just be running for another term in the
white house he'll be running away from
legal troubles possible criminal charges
and even the specter of prison time
in recent months trump has made clear to
associates with the legal protections of
occupying the oba
that the legal protections of occupying
the oval office are front of mind for
him
for people with knowledge of the
situation tell rolling stone trump has
spoken about how when you were the
president of the united states it is
tough for politically motivated
prosecutors to get to you says one of
the sources who discussed the issue with
trump this summer he says when not if he
is president again a new republican
administration will put a stop to the
justice department investigation that he
views as the biden administration
working to hit him with criminal charges
or even put him and his people in prison
now that would be a pretty interesting
campaign platform i need this job to
stay out of prison but
the craziest part of all of it i've said
before
trump is a symptom
but the real disease disease are the
people who give him money and who vote
for him if you just had trump and nobody
paid attention and nobody would be would
vote for him we wouldn't be in the mess
that we're in
even if trump admitted in a fundraising
email to donors i need you to donate so
i can become president because otherwise
they're going to put me in prison if he
just said it that way which is maybe
what he increasingly believes his cult
is trained to think he's smart
for committing obvious crimes and
getting away with them or
that it's all a witch hunt and people
are coming after him they're not
actually conditioned to think critically
did he do anything wrong when he called
and pressured georgia and said i need
eleven hundred eleven thousand seven
hundred and eighty votes give me a break
when he said that stuff
it must have been because he really won
right i mean if they're just going after
him it's a witch hunt and there's a
couple of different really important
implications to this number one
he
a
a normal candidate and or a normal
country
would never have made him the nominee in
the first place if he had become the
nominee they never would have elected
him to the presidency
if they had elected him to the
presidency presidency and he did the
things he did
they would have demanded him removed in
a way that
elected officials could not have ignored
25th amendment whatever impeachment and
removal
and had that happened or either way once
the first term is done
uh given the things that he did he would
have no shot whatsoever of raising money
and getting to power again that's not
the situation in the united states
situation in the united states is the
access hollywood tape making fun of
disabled reporters all the little things
that early would have just knocked him
out didn't he consolidated support he
activated the lowest of the low
information voters people who were in
many cases not even engaged in politics
before and built a movement around it
and now the test will be are they still
with them tens of millions are but he
doesn't need just tens of millions he
probably needs between 65 and 85 million
can he still get that number and can he
get it by admitting the reason that he's
running
um another aspect to this
if trump sees
2024
as the way to remain a free man and
maybe not literally free from prison but
just free from being in court for the
next 10 years of his life
um it means he will do whatever he feels
he needs to do to destroy anybody who
gets in his way and that includes ron
desantis that includes greg abbott that
includes fox news which by the way we'll
talk later increasingly seems to be
setting themselves up to bail on trump
and to support desantis the cult base
won't turn on him can he build a big
enough group of gullible people to get
the again it's an estimate 65 probably
at this point it's more like 70 to 85
million votes that he would need uh what
happens with the never trumpers what
happens with the q anon crazies you've
got the trump cultists the old school
republicans the disaffected moderates
the clueless people who just follow
celebrities into politics or whatever
the case may be all questions to which
we don't yet have answers but the report
now is trump is running he may announce
even before the midterms and he's doing
it and he will be doing it because he
sees it as the way to stay out of
criminal charges the next question is is
it likely that those criminal charges
are actually coming
there is a legal expert normizen
who believes at this point without a
doubt that donald trump is heading
towards an indictment and that trump's
allies have started to relieve to
receive target letters which are
different than we want you to testify
target letters are you are actually a
target in this investigation
um let's discuss
with the caveat that great until trump
is actually charged i remain skeptical
that anything's going to happen newsweek
report trump heading towards an
indictment as allies receive warnings
attorney norman eisen predicted friday
that former president donald trump is
heading towards an indictment in georgia
after some of his allies there received
so-called target letters from the fulton
county da's office now i want to remind
everybody
a month ago maybe six weeks ago i said
that i don't think charges against trump
are likely
but if there are going to be charges
i believe the likeliest source
is the investigation in georgia where
there was so much evidence recorded
evidence phone calls pressure campaigns
back channels trying to get specific
georgia officials this wasn't just oh i
went on the news and said i won or we
held a hearing where rudy giuliani had
flatulence and also you know what said
that i won this was specific phone calls
this was targeting brad raffensberger
this was
sending lindsey graham deputizing
lindsey graham to go in and say well
can't we look at it and see if maybe we
can do something find a different
conclusion i believe that the most
likely source of charges would be
georgia and that is indeed what normizen
is saying
the georgia county d.a fannie willis
launched the investigation into trump
early last year after he pressured
officials in the state to help overturn
president joe biden's election win
that effort drew national attention
after audio of a call between trump and
georgia's secretary of state brad
raffensberger leaked in which trump or
urged him to find enough votes to change
the outcome yahoo news first reported
friday that david shaffer the state of
republican chair in georgia and state
senators bert jones in brandon beach
have received target letters from willis
warning they could face indictment in
connection to her investigation jeff
desantis a spokesperson for the d.a also
said willis is considering subpoenaing
trump to testify before the special
grand jury convened for the probe eisen
said to the new york times i do believe
that the great likelihood is he's
heading towards an indictment
the legal expert previously served
special counsel to the house judiciary
during trump's first impeachment
there is powerful proof of violations of
georgia law in the form of the smoking
gun tape of him demanding eleven
thousand seven hundred and eighty votes
when it is perfectly clear from the tape
that he knows the votes don't exist yes
and that is an important point
some have very meekly and flaccidly and
not
credibly tried to defend trump's request
for 11 780 votes by saying
he's not saying fraudulently get me
those votes he's just saying
i believe i really won
it's not that big of a gap to overcome
let's find legal votes
anyone who has listened to that tape
knows that that is not at all what he
was trying to say so
fascinating interesting the news
headlines for the last three years have
been trump is heading to an indictment
uh personally i know people convinced
that donald trump is going to be charged
and we may see headlines for the next
six months saying any day now any day
now trump's going to be charged if it
happens i will be the first to tell you
i am not confident that that's going to
take place now one other thing and i
want to think ahead here a little bit
because this is another important issue
imagine trump gets indicted okay
imagine that the indictment goes to
trial unlikely but imagine we get
through those two steps imagine that
there's a jury trial
how do you get a jury
that will be able to properly and fairly
adjudicate a donald trump case if you
have one trump cultist on the jury you
have a hung jury how do you even do jury
selection i mean think about how do you
find someone who has no opinion about
trump and no significant preconceived
notions of his guilt or innocence and
then the the next layer is if you think
about there are non-political people
there are people who know nothing and
care nothing about who's president they
just don't pay attention
but are those people we trust to be in
the position of even adjudicating the
case think about people you know who
have no idea
what has gone on the last six years are
those people that we would be confident
saying this is a jury of our peers and
they will adjudicate this doesn't seem
like it to me so that's sort of like a
second order issue if we ever got an
indictment and had to pick a jury but
we'll deal with that later nor eisen
says trump is heading towards an
indictment and at least to some degree
trump must think it's possible because
the report from rolling stone is he
plans to run for 24 and it's to keep
himself out of prison essentially away
from criminal charges as he sees it
what do you expect let me know
follow us on social media interact with
the david pakman show community see
exclusive content see when we're taking
calls live and stay up to date on other
big show announcements we post daily
find us on reddit twitter instagram
facebook discord and tick tock
well per a number of reports including
ones we looked at earlier donald trump
is getting ready to announce his 2024
republican primary presidential
candidacy number of reasons why he's
looking to do it it seems pretty clear
now it does seem as though
his mood is not quite right donald trump
spent the better part of sunday
afternoon absolutely losing it on truth
social his uh social media platform
whose name even he gets wrong sometimes
he delivered a 14 post screed all within
a short period of time sunday afternoon
and something seems to be very very
wrong
donald trump starting by posting a
breitbart article about how mike lee is
leading evan mccullen
i believe his name is actually mcmullen
but you know who cares right uh in
utah's senate the utah senate's general
election race trump likes mike lee mike
lee is a trumpist then trump posts an
article from the federalists saying that
courts have ruled states didn't follow
their own election laws in 2020.
this is a very popular claim part of the
dozen or two dozen however you know
different claims that are being made by
uh trump republicans about the 2020
election that states didn't follow their
own laws now as we've covered before and
covered pretty extensively uh what they
mean by that is that in some states
rules about elections were changed
without going through the legislature
that's different than states didn't
follow their own laws what it means is
that
other reasons in particular the pandemic
were used to say actually we're going to
let whoever wants to vote absentee vote
absentee of course they have to go
through the process i have to be
registered to vote have to be citizens
all they have to be alive all these
different things and it's just a talking
point the states didn't states broke
their own laws no the just the the rules
for how to run an election were modified
in ways consistent with the law trump
then posting an article from
townhall.com trump was right they're
sending their rapists now this is of
course related to the story of the 10
year old girl who was tragically raped
and impregnated in ohio and due to
ohio's abortion law had to leave ohio go
to indiana
to obtain an abortion
this is now as i said last week the the
thing they're going to focus on at first
they said the story was was made up
uh christie gnome
jim jordan
it's a long list of different people who
said the story is just fake there is no
10 year old girl or if there is she
wasn't raped or if she was raped she
wasn't impregnated if she was
impregnated she didn't really need to go
to indiana well it all happened it then
was learned that the believed
perpetrator
is allegedly undocumented now they care
about the story but not about the part
that we've been talking about so trump
then goes to that then trump posts an
article from hannity worst president
ever after the inflation report worst
president trends on twitter now of
course as i'm sure you know by now
inflation has nothing to do with joe
biden inflation is happening globally
it's much higher than in the u.s in some
countries it's much lower than in the
u.s in some countries it doesn't have
anything to do with biden trump's just
rapid fire posting this stuff
okay
next trump posts the picture
of the alleged rapist in the 10 year old
ohio story
of course saying that there's a cover-up
of the fact that he's believed to be an
illegal immigrant there is no such
cover-up i reported it to you within the
first minute of telling you the story
the real cover-up is they are covering
up the fact that they called the story
fake for a week until they could no
longer deny it and none of them
apologize for it trump tweeting about
that tweeting sorry
truthing about that
trump then posting an oversized image
related to inflation
and the changes to inflation which of
course
have nothing to do with joe biden so
trump jumping on that one just rapid
fire desperate desperate trump
trump then posting an article from yahoo
news called daily this is john daly a
pro-trump golfer
daily calls for british open return to
daddy trump's turnberry um the british
open was taken out of trump's golf
course john daly likes trump and trump
signal boosting that
what is trump doing that he has so much
time trump then posting an article from
just the news not a particularly
trustworthy website bombshells undercut
the big lie
21 confirmed illegalities and
irregularities from 2020.
folks
um
million votes
150 million votes
they have now found think about this
they have now found after nearly two
years
21
instances
of wrongdoing 21
150 million people voted trump wants us
to see it and say wow i guess he was
right then trump with a breitbart
article exclusive trump endorsed senate
candidate mark wayne mullen the red wave
is real and it's coming
meaningless article the red wave may be
coming but all polling is showing a
dramatic shift away from republicans and
towards democrats thanks to what
happened with roe v wade thanks to what
has not happened on gun safety which is
nothing has happened trump then posting
a graph he probably doesn't even
understand exclusive blake masters trump
endorsement has been like rocket fuel
for this campaign
uh maybe i mean okay let's wait and see
what happens there
trump then posting from the
insanely dangerous and weaponized
conspiracy website the gateway pundit
trump appointed judge blox air force
from expelling unvaccinated service
members and enforcing vaccine mandate
just anti-vaxx pablum
that we've seen from trump
trump then with an article from right
side broadcasting another extreme
right-wing media outlet
tim michaels will win
if he remains strong on the rigged and
stolen election trump says otherwise he
has no chance increasingly untrue
actually talking about the rigged and
stolen stolen election seems to pull
worse and worse even with republican
voters and then donald trump posting a
video of mark levin from fox news
claiming that the january sixth
committee is a setup to quote kill
the republican party
trump then posting a video of sean
hannity talking to laura ingram on fox
news and then donald trump saying the
unselect committee and the fake news
media refused to go anywhere near these
two topics especially the rigged
election where the evidence of fraud is
incontestable this is a former president
folks
just just posting posting posting then
trump posting memes
one about how
people had more savings under trump and
of course the reason for that is
everything was closed
and everything being closed and people
just sitting at home due to the pandemic
increase the savings rate many countries
saw that had nothing to do with trump
and by the way the funniest part about
bragging about the larger savings rate
under trump is a high savings rate is
not considered particularly good for the
economy and what i mean by that is when
you save money in a savings account
you're not injecting it into the economy
it's
under traditional economic thinking
which people like trump
claim to believe in and support
um
you don't want people saving do you want
people spending this is something they
talk about all the time and then also
donald trump uh congratulating cam smith
on winning the open championship at
saint andrews okay nobody really cares
about that a 14 post screed
and trump is reportedly panicked about
forthcoming criminal charges and
believed to be announcing his 2024 run
very soon
i have to tell you part of me wonders
and thinks
might be interesting to let him back on
twitter what would he even do if he was
allowed back on twitter i am going to
play a video video for you from fox news
that makes it very clear fox news is
positioning itself
to hit the abort button on supporting
donald trump they're getting ready to
dump trump and support ron desantis in
2024 but they're leaving themselves an
open window
to support trump if trump is the nominee
so if if you were doubting that fox news
would rather trump not be the nominee
check out this
deliberately edited
man on the street type segment where fox
news reporters went out
and they were talking to random trump
voters and the question was do you want
trump to run again
or not and of course
they could have crafted this in any way
that they want you can just keep
interviewing people until you get the
clips that you want
they selected mostly random trump voters
who don't want trump running in 2024 it
is very clear that fox news is setting
themselves up to abort the trump train
take a look at this i don't want him to
i like uh like what he stands for i like
what he does but
he uh upset too many people and he upset
him really bad so i don't think he's
good for the party he needs to get back
in
he already had gained that respect from
all the world leaders and finish what he
you know started by the way that's the
random trump supporter in there he
gained respect from world leaders world
leaders were laughing at him
literally both behind his back and
sometimes to his face behind his back at
a number of different different summits
to his face at that wacky un speech
where the room just started laughing at
trump
respect it's too bad that he did what he
did do and was fought the whole way
along on
star near everything that he did but
that's what happened so i'd
like to see him not run if he did i
would vote for him but i would not
recommend he runs i i voted for trump
both times and i i love him i think he
was a good candidate but i think his
time has passed i couldn't care less
about uh president trump uh personally
um
i i prefer somebody different but if he
is the nominee i'll probably vote for
him you know what i voted for him for my
my very first time i voted for him i
don't think it'll be best for our
country for him to
run for re-election you know i'm
thankful for everything that he's done
but i think that our republican party
needs to be united at this point he's a
little too polarizing and i think that
there are candidates out there
republican candidates obviously
that um
maybe be able to pull in people that he
would lose to be able to change this i
would like to see you know governor
desantis or someone like that some some
new blood in in the race desantis
run for president and if he wants to
then he could pick up donald as the vice
president we're from florida um
desantis is we're big fans of desantis
on this one he seems to be much more
common sense
and able to communicate better to both
sides
to get those people back then
so remember they could have picked
anybody they could interview that
they're only including a few people in
this they could have interviewed 50 or
60 or 70 people and gotten whatever they
wanted everybody's saying trump should
run or not everybody's saying to santa
they have chosen these people to create
this story
he's done a good job and everything he's
tried to do despite all you know it's
not all just what he says it doesn't
just happen like that
i believe he's done a good job with a
lot of things and that's just my
personal beliefs i really like desantis
all right so you get it
fox is in total control of this story
they could make it say anything they
could turn it into a campaign ad for
trump if they wanted it they are looking
towards the future
they seem to think the future is not
trump and the long-term
viability of fox news as a business
enterprise depends on it being sort of
like the state media arm
of some republican authoritarian regime
and so this is self-interest at work i
want people to understand that it's not
about they like trump's foreign policy
or they don't like it or whatever
uh the idea here is they want
to get someone other than trump in
if trump ends up winning the nomination
of course they will still back him but
right now they're saying we think we
will be better off
with the old version of fox where we
just all get behind a more
popular authoritarian right-wing regime
rather than someone who's is polarizing
and so they've crafted this narrative
everybody seems to want desantis
we will see
how the primary shakes out if and when
people announced neither trump nor
desantis have yet announced but this is
probably part of why trump would rather
make the announcement sooner than later
that he's running and um it will be
to his advantage in order to push people
to have to take more of a risk to not
support him right now with no one
declared it's easier for fox to run
these pieces hey look it just sort of
seems like the public wants someone else
and that someone else happens to be ron
desantis if trump announces
it puts them in a much more difficult
position to keep running anti-trump
pro-desantis pieces so that's to trump's
interest then to announce sooner every
indication is that he's going to do that
we have a voicemail number and that
number is 2192 david p
after i posted a horrible horrible
voicemail i received to my instagram the
eggman who has done time in prison and
is a jewish man himself and that's
relevant to the story he called in to
weigh in on it take a listen to this
hey dave i just went on instagram and
listened to that voice message from the
guy in carolina down south to saying he
wants actually west virginia smacked a
taste out of your mouth he was horribly
uh anti-semitic and does not like you
dave i just want to tell you about those
people i know them for real i work with
them but best of all i was in prison
with them dave you know i have a giant
star of david tattoo on my back i am
obviously freaking jewish okay there are
actual nazis in prison when these people
saw me with the star david tattoo
walking around the yard or in the tv
room with no shirt on do you know what
they did to me david
they asked me for legal help and to get
them leave
shalom brother
so the the eggman i guess playing up
some uh some stereotypical tropes there
but i think his main point is
that when he faced some of these
anti-semites in person
they weren't
willing to do the things they were
willing to maybe do online i guess
that's the point that the eggman is
making there sort of interesting i guess
but always appreciate
his insights that's for sure
uh okay on today's bonus show we will be
talking about georgia's second largest
school district allowing non-officers to
carry guns
they're doing it
it's happening
also
wealthy countries are talking about
fourth covet shots
tailored coveted shots
much of africa still hasn't gotten any
doses and we're going to talk about that
and third this story going viral bmw the
vehicle manufacturer bmw
is offering heated seats on a monthly
subscription the car comes equipped with
them but you can only turn them on with
a monthly subscription what how does
that work we will talk about it on
today's bonus show get instant access by
signing up at joinpackman.com
you can use the coupon code bigboating22
we will see you then